so I did not pick the title again so
it's a rather broad and but this is the
first in a series of four talks the
second one of which will be right after
lunch then on Friday we'll have two
other talks that will focus more on
applications of discontinuous methods
and today what I want to focus on is
really taking the theme of this program
at ab and bridging the continuous and
discrete in the design of first-order
methods and yeah really
when I say continuous I really mean
continuous not continuous like this I
really mean continuous like this and
part of my rationale for doing this is
that a lot of the problems we have in
the discrete setting have a specific
structure which is not which sometimes
is not captured by the kind of standard
assumptions people take in this world in
the design of safe first order methods
for cons of convex optimization and so
if we want to come up with a better way
to fit our methods to the specifications
and the properties of the discrete world
we need really to go back all the way to
the origin to where these first order
methods come from which is continuous
dynamics
right so I also like this continuous
point of view and first order methods a
lot because it allows you to first unify
the understanding of lots of different
methods but also really to approach the
design of an iterative algorithm in a
very principled and almost mechanical
way and that's the main takeaway that I
want you to take away from from this
hour here is how more than specific
technical results I want you to take
away what kind of principle you want to
keep in mind when you try to understand
or design a first order method be it for
a discrete problem or a continuous
disclaimer I'm gonna be morally correct
in most of the math but there are going
to be a few things swept under the
carpet feel free to point them out but
we have a draft of a paper that contains
all the proofs and only what totally
through all the derivation and I should
just mention that you can find that on
the web page of my postdoc Lillian
adapter connect Hollis so later today
we wrote it all right so I should
mention also the I'm not gonna mention
lots of references because there's a
vast area but I should mention it
recently there have been a number of
papers trying to understand first of the
methods from this continuous dynamic
point of view and including papers from
a number of people here and the one
thing I want to different today is
rather than focusing I wanna think about
this first order matters discretization
of physical systems rather than thinking
about my physical system in a Newtonian
mechanics point of view when I think of
a particle and I say or there is a
gradient like a force pulling me this
way there is a potential pulling me this
way what's the colibri oh I'm going to
take a more interesting point of view
which is a kind of analytical mechanics
point of view which is that there are
some invariant that are preserved in
this system and I want at my particle is
going to follow the path that preserves
a certain invariant and these invariants
are actually value so because they turn
out to be related to the duality gap to
the quality of the solution so certain
quantity related to the current quality
of the solution is preserved throughout
all these dynamics also I will pack the
trigram G's Italian which out nice you
might think is French it is Italian look
it up and I also like that this provides
a kind of connection to lots of areas of
physics and dynamical systems that are
very interesting ok so let me first talk
a bit about the most the simplest kind
of model that which is the model we'll
be working with today this is the kind
of conversation with a first-order
Oracle it's very simple you're trying to
minimize the convex function and you
have the way this convex function is
presented to you is through about a
black box so you feed it a point X and
you go back the function value and the
gradient
turns out you don't even need the
function right the gradient is enough
let's say you also get the function and
everything is exactly the function is
come back so it's a you have lots of
assumptions you can make and your goal
is to ask discrete time your goal is to
ask a small number of queries to this
black box and then output some X which
is only apps run away from the object
from the optimum in function
so in continuous-time things so can be
different essentially you can
instantaneously query this box and at
every time T you get the function value
on a gradient then you can use these two
values from the black box to define a
dynamic so the sign so you can write an
OD an ordinary differential equation
that involves these terms and evolve
your system in that way so the most
basic thing you can do is called
gradient flow which is the time
derivative of your ax equals exactly the
gradient so you move in the direction of
the gradient I'm gonna use this dot
notation to mean the time derivative so
this is DX DT
and then the kind of analysis the will
try to do is to I mean either you use a
conservation principle or a potential
principle which in this case is called
the hakuna argument to get convergence
to get asymptotic convergence for
dynamic and then we are going to use
very simple like well-understood schemes
in the numerical analysis for the ease
to discretize this course because this
curve s are useless if we cannot
discretize we are going to build it in
this is for very basic we're gonna build
in the step size and that will be
necessary because different methods will
need different step sizes and you can
also incorporate adaptive step sizes so
step size is fundamental that's what
when it comes in step size comes in in
this position there is no step size in
the continuous sort and I should mention
the continuous word that you can rescale
time there is no issues of convergence
like if your algorithm converge if you
write it down in a way that you get
convergence in like this square you can
rescale T Square to be your new T and
you still get so you shouldn't take the
the audio behavior is not going to tell
you much about the actual convergence
that's a rate of convergence it tells
about the convergence at infinity to
leave me understand the convergence you
need to understand the discretization
okay so I think when I started to look
at this the first thing I thought about
was you know gradient flow seems great
because it makes you move in a direction
that always reduces the function value
so why should there be anything else
why should we do anything else then
it'll flow the corresponding discrete
algorithm is gradient descent and there
is there are a few arguments why
gradient descent and gradient flow do
not cut it the first argument is that
some functions are non smooth when I say
nose mode it means that the gradient can
change abruptly so the gradient is not
Lipschitz continuous so in this case at
this point the gradient all of a sudden
jumps up and that's an issue for the
discretization of gradient flow because
when you're doing Bayesian flow if you
are here if you're on this bit of the
curve you really would like to take a
long set because you're seeing this very
steep slope but if you take a long slide
but you're going to overshoot completely
the other end you might be on this side
of the curve and then you should take
then you are inclined to take a small
step but really should take a long step
so you don't have any information about
this kind of problem if if the gradient
can change arbitrarily quickly and so no
discretization is a big obstacle for non
smooth functions and will come up with a
way to deal with that explicit and then
there is another issue which is even
more fundamental is that knowing that
the function value decreases is actually
very little informative in terms of
proving rate of convergence because you
need to know compared to what compared
to where the optimum is we want to prove
something we want to prove a theoretical
bound on convergence so in a way not
only we need to decrease our function
value but we also need to construct some
kind of lower bound to optima and
prove or at least the implicit will
prove that just to converge together so
the real idea is that the real thing we
should try to optimize is not really the
function value but is some notion of
duality gap so the first part of this
arc we really thank you for concern what
is notion of duality gap please
and actually to give an example of what
happens is here are two dynamics this is
the gradient further man dynamics it
corresponds to gradient descent and this
is something called the accelerated
dynamic and so this one may look like
it's longer and it converge and if it's
like it's it doesn't have this nice
smooth behavior that's million descent
but this one the red curve leads to
faster algorithms for two related
reasons one reason is that this red
curve is actually trying to optimize the
notion of duality gap and the other
reason is that even though this curve is
longer you'll notice that it has longer
straight segments so this curve is
actually easier to discretize it kind of
corresponds to what people and in this
case this is actually is smooth strongly
convex function and this came actually
from linear system and this would
actually be related to cherish the
iteration
so let me start to put down some markers
so the way we want to think of our
algorithm is that at every iteration you
know at every iteration we have some
candidate solution which I'm gonna call
X bar and that X bar is gonna define an
upper bound to our objective and and at
the same time we want to use the
gradient information you are recovering
to also define the lower bound and our
goal is to somehow sure that those upper
bound and upper bounds are close to each
other and we're actually gonna you can
actually explicitly main thing is that
per bound and upper bound I'm going to
call them u T and L T and notice that UT
may be the function value at X bar it
might also be something else it might be
a relaxation of it so it's in some sense
what we'll see is that our choice put
what we call upper bound and lower bound
is going to determine whatever algorithm
looks like and eventually you know we
want to show statements of this kind the
duality gap which is upper bound minus
lower bound is less than epsilon for
some large enough
so so that's the way we're gonna handle
you're gonna think about duality gap and
as I said that the whole in this way of
presenting things the the algorithm is
completely determined by your choice of
upper bound and lower bound so you tell
me what is your upper bound which is a
lower bound and like as a boxer spits
out an algorithm because essentially
disapper bound is over bound will define
this physical invariant I'm talking
about and so this works great for the
continuous world but then we also care
about discretizing so the other thing
what this allows you to do is you're
gonna pick upper bound a lower bound in
a way that guarantees that you can
discretize the continuous dynamically
that you get and the main concept in the
division step that we are going to care
about whether our functions are smooth
or not and we're also going to care
about what kind of primitives we have
available you'll see that in general
just having a gradient article is not
enough to solve these problems
[Music]
so let me tell you quickly more
precisely what I mean by smoothness so a
function convex function f is smooth on
X if it's you know if the rate at which
derivatives change is just a nap ok so
here I'm sweeping lots of stuff under
the market that is I'm assuming and I
should say in this talk I'm always
assuming that F is differentiable you
can still do complex optimization even
if your function is not differentiable
under sanction as something called sub
gradients but let's think when I what I
say is actually price to the non
differentiable case just imagine that
this gradient of F is a choice of sub
gradient at the point so let's not worry
about the gradient so this condition of
smoothness is actually important because
it will allow us it's important for the
audience will write because it will
essentially ensure that a solution
exists to do these studies and the kind
of it's very important for the
discretization because intuitively if
you are at a human innovation decency
and your function is smooth so the
gradient changes in a controlled way you
can take a step and as you take your
step you know in the beginning your step
as it's completely parallel to the
gradient field and as you move its going
to stay parallel for at least some some
stretch and in that stretch you are
making progress so that's the whole idea
of smoothness is that it allows you to
say I can make a step that is at least a
certain length because within that ball
my gradients look like the original
aggregate
the star okay so the norm since I using
this target general norms so this could
be the primal norm and it is the dual
norm you can think of as 202 can think
of l1 and infinity and this is general
for non Euclidean norms lots more
complicated knows
so there are many ways so the way I
chose to present this involves giving
you some rudiments of conjugate
functions and constant duality I liked
this presentation because this
presentation you get a framework in
which your primal problem the problem of
creating an upper bound and the problem
of creating a lower bound are identical
are symmetric and I think that's a very
nice feature so the first point I want
to make is that there is kind of a
syntactical problem if you think about
it if you are if I only give you a black
box article to the gradient you
essentially have a map that goes from a
point ax in your feasible set in your
primer space I'm a solution it goes to a
gradient but the gradients that don't
live in the space so it's not really
clear how are you gonna change your X by
knowing a vector you know rendering a
function of are you gonna map a
functional back to the space of
solutions so you need some kind of math
that goes backwards from gradients to
solutions you know you could say just
take the identities that's what you do
if you just take a step in the direction
of the gradient but in general you need
some rationale for choosing this map and
which will call middle map so let me
give you so one way to define these kind
of maps so what are the kind of maps
that met from gradient functionals back
to the primal space so did typical kind
of maps of this kind are conjugate
functions many of you probably know this
but what is the complex conjugate so if
I have a function G compass function
here G here in red
the compass can get disturbed is a
function that takes as input really a
vector functional think of it as a
possible gradient and then optimizes
this expression and you can think about
that
as maximizing the difference between
this blue line which is the functional
defined by Z and your your convex
function so whenever this is maximized
this quantity this translation is G star
of Z more interesting than G star of Z
is what the gradient of G star of Z
let's think about that the gradient of G
star of Z is well if you think about it
by an optimality condition so think
about the the Maximizer you for this
expression by optimality conditions the
Maximizer you as to obey this
first-order condition if I differentiate
here I get the gradient of G at my
Maximizer must equal to Z and it turns
out that this Maximizer U is actually
the gradient of G Star so all of that to
say that the easiest way I have to think
about this conjugate function which is
under mild assumption like this actually
only works for strictly convex function
is that G Star the gradient of G Star is
the inverse of the gradient of G I'm
gonna in some sense this is not this
requires some assumptions but all the
proofs I'm gonna show based on this fact
can be easily generalized to the more
general case so we're going to work with
this throat stock think of the gradient
of G Star is simply going to be the
inverse map for the gradient of G this
is gonna let me talk about maps that now
take gradients and bring them back into
primer space and there is a similar
definition for concave functions that I
actually it comes in the next ride and
another useful thing to know is that
under very mild assumptions the the dual
of the dual that the conjugate dual of
the conjugate dual is the function
itself
and there's a similar concept for
concave functions and it's essentially
exactly the same except you have mean
instead of Max okay so now that we have
covered the conjugate duality let's go
back to our problem so what should I put
it
and the idea is that I'm going to think
of some math sighs some function of side
and the gradient of the conjugate up
side is going to provide this math back
and I'm gonna call this the mirror map
and this is the mirror function side let
me so this guy is kind of important
because so the intuition for why so
there are lots of different ways of
understanding what the roll up side is
first kind of sigh is gonna allow you to
define the to have a simple definition
of a notion of lower bound of a dual of
the dual notion by 2 conjugate duality
in algorithmic really kind of you're
going to think of psy as a problem
that's easy to solve because the whole
point of introducing this tie is that
the gradient of size tab is something
you can compute the point is that I
wanted I'm gonna assume from now on that
I can compute this map from sample size
okay so sigh this immediately means to
the size is an easy solution to optimize
over because if I query the gradient of
psy style at 0 I'm just gonna get the
Arg max subside size concave socks I is
an easy function to optimize with and
this also means that you can actually
formally think do things fat where you
can actually formally think of science
as a pre-conditioner in the sense that
if psy is close to f this is you know
the fact that psy is easy to optimize
makes it easy to optimize f
and good so that's some intuition about
sigh and then the last thing in country
duality that is actually very useful is
to understand for the purposes of
discretization so we need to understand
if a function f is smooth what what can
we say about its conjugant and it turns
out that if F is convex and smooth its
conjugate is convex and strongly convex
with a 1 over a stronger term laxity
parameter so that's the background now
we're going to start deriving some
algorithms questions so that's it they
related also by an inverse relation but
that's a bit more complicated and in
general is that they don't have to be
twice differentiable these functions any
other questions ok so let's start
working with actual problems and the
kind of optimization problems I want to
solve the first are called composite
optimization these are particularly nice
for this framework I started to sketch
because the objective itself as a
composite form so the objective is -
some convex is a minimize some convex
function - some concave function and
these functions are exactly the ones
that I have access to in my black box in
my black boys so sometimes I have an
aura called a gradient article that
takes me some solutions to gradients for
F and I have a gradient article that
takes me from ingredients back to
solutions for psy
and what we're going to care about is
whether these map and this map are
smooth or non smooth
so what's an example of like a typical
composite problem suppose you have a
smooth optimization problem over a
positive a smooth function over a
Pulitzer then you can write it as
minimize FX this is the smooth part and
this is just the indicator function of s
what's the function that's 0 it's a
complex function that's zero on the
polytope s and plus infinity everywhere
else so these are going to be in the my
F and my minus I and we assume that we
have access to the gradient of F what
does it mean to have access to the
gradient of psystar but the gradient of
psystar as this definition because this
is the indicator the the gradient of Phi
the the mirror map is exactly this
problem which is just a linear
optimization over s so the way the
mirror map works is you give me a
gradient and I'm gonna find the point
that minimizes that linear function over
the polytope this is going to give rise
to Frank old methods
and in this case what do we know about
our Maps we know that this F is smooth
so this map here is Lipschitz continuous
this indicator function is it's a very
non smooth function because if it goes
from 0 to infinity and it's not hard to
see that it's mirror map it's also known
as most we have a setting in which in
one direction we are most and in the
other we are non smooth okay so so sigh
it's it's just something that we have to
assume you're given in practice you will
want to design sigh and we'll get to
that but sigh it's something that we
assume is given in this contest of
composite optimization Phi is actually
part of the object besides society is
actually concretely
and motivated
I started different way earlier so why
should the mirror not respond to this
part
well the dizzy
clearly if you have this kind of
function this is a natural way of the
compositing in this way this right this
is kind of more general view of what
Webster is will come more into play when
you don't either composites problem when
you just have a problem like this and
then you need to come up with website
yourself I will recover your data later
so complex optimization is a very
restricted setting because you know the
two articles that you have the primary
and two articles also come from the
function that are in the objective in
general that's not true in general you
just have convex function and you need
to come up with this and that's where
the intuition about preconditioning
comes in good question any other
questions
so whatever solution you saw as we
construct our solutions again let's go
back to this kind of syntactic way of
the problem we're going to get a bunch
of primer points and we're going to
maintain our current solution X bar and
this primal points even the only way in
which we get primal points is by
querying our mirror map so dev iteration
will even get some timer point and you
can actually show that you know the
right way to construct X bar is by
taking some distribution some complex
distribution of the primal points you've
seen so far this can be actually firmly
made format and for this reason I'm
going to define X bar in this way so let
me pass that
okay so what is alpha so I'm gonna think
of kind of the timeline and in some
sense I want to allow myself to give
different way to different importance to
different points in this timeline or can
they'll get different speeds is also
going to be useful for discretization
and that's your point of defining this
alpha this alpha is really just a
measure over over the time line
this can be the cumulative distribution
would be out of T and alpha prime of T
it's the density function and I'm we'll
figure out later about alpha is to be
actually we need to figure it out when
when we discretize but this is just a
convenient way actually of not talking
about step plants keeping your step
lines one and working with the alpha two
to define the scale
okay so another thing I want to mention
I'm trying to create a convex
combination of these points
the reason I'm adding x0 is because I
want my point
I want my dynamic to be differentiable
at time 0 so essentially what's going to
happen is from time 0 to time 1 I'm
gonna stay at x0 so and so I'm really
giving a weight of 1 to the point x0 and
then I'm gonna give a weight of alpha
dot of T to our subsequent points this
way this becomes a convex combination
exactly
because this will come up a lot I'm just
gonna use this a bag notation there's
some measure over time so this is going
to be the way I define X bar is actually
convenient because when you actually
prove this formally this you can easily
turn this into a discrete measure and
most of the proofs go through so it's
very convenient for this position
exactly the same picture on the dual
side I'm gonna get a bunch of dual
solutions disease by queer ingredients
and I'm gonna maintain my current
solution as an average of disease okay
so finally we are ready to define some
upper bounds and some lower bounds and
some notion of duality gap okay so what
should I take my upper bound to be the
most natural choice is this is the
function value at my current solution
remember my function is f minus I so my
notion of upper bound would be f of X
bar minus PI of X bar and you can
differentiate that and this is the
derivative you get but this is a way in
which the current solution changes so
this is all great when you do this
position if FM sy are smooth so if these
guys don't change the quickly these guys
changed quickly you'll not be able to
discretize you know we won't be able to
integrate this which you need to do when
you discretize so instead suppose so say
for the for example that sy is not as
much so if sy is a if you know the
tristar is not more 2 so if this map is
not Lipschitz sorry all right if if sy
is known as mode so if this map is not
continuous not Lipschitz continuous we
need to do something else and that
something else is gonna be this nice
trick which instead of using f of X bar
and side effects pad I'm gonna keep f of
X bar because I'm assuming F is smooth
and instead of using sy of X bar
I'm gonna use the fact that X bar is an
average of points and then I use
Jensen's inequality to use the average
of the size at the points that make up X
bar this realize key on the fact that
this current solution on maintaining is
an average of things so while the
evolution of psi X bar may be non smooth
once I start bounding it by an average
of things these things is most this is a
way of taking an upper bound which is
non smooth and using concavity in this
case turning it into one which is going
to be smooth although it is going to be
much weaker it's gonna actually lead to
slower algorithms but things we can
discretize
any questions about upper bound
this point is important
when you get a function example all the
points you see add-ins are inside so
it's not a problem
and inside the politic yeah
okay let's talk about lower bounds now
and about what's you know however want
to construct rubber bounds and so the
following is really I'm gonna show that
there is a special function you can
write off gradients that defines a lower
bound that's the consequence of this
conjugate the framework we have
introduced so for a complex function how
would you go about designing a lower
bound the way you would go about
designing a lower bound is whenever you
query point and you get a gradient you
have a lower bound for your function if
you're optimizing over some say compact
set you know that the the minimum of
this function provides a global lower
bound we were optimization problem
that's why it was solution same works if
you have a bunch of points so
distribution of our points you queried
you can take all these different lower
bounding hyperplanes
and take their average the ravages to
the lower bound then you can minimize
that average and I will give you a
global over bounds for your function so
the point is that the notion of a dual
solution is a convex combination of
gradient what is not nice about this is
that if I want to evaluate what my lower
bound is I need to keep around all this
stuff or this other information which is
not a gradient current reality helps you
simplify this expression and intuition
is this okay
so I did this for us but I can actually
add because I care about sigh I cannot
now add side on both sides of my
expression and then I can minimize on
both sides so when I minimize then I
know that X f of X star minus rally
effects tab which is my optimum is lower
bounded by this expression but now I
have a minimization over you in here
and the minimization includes sigh so
this is the main this is a kind of the
key trick and this country oddity is
that now this term ear looks like a
conjurer to duel or something actually
you can mess we can make this term also
look like a conch with doer and you get
this lower bound you get your optimum is
at least sized star so the conjugate
develops I of an average of gradients
minus F star of an average of gradient
and so these average of Radiance is what
I'm going to think of as my dual
solution so when I think about the dual
solution I'm going to take some average
of gradients and plug it in into this
function yeah so yeah this is for all
you so some this is for all you and I
just took it by adding side on both
sides and then here i minimized over you
and so when i minimize the value I'm
gonna get this min here and the mean is
gonna involve my side of you know so I
got what I really got here is the
conjugate of psy at this average of
gradients and what I got on this side is
the mean of a few minus IU which is off
there are fathers that yeah they also
moved inside doesn't matter it's didn't
fit in there yeah that doesn't that
doesn't matter I also moved it inside
because I wanted to emphasize the these
both listen these seven average
okay so essentially what we derive now
is a way to think about it dual
objective and that's in a nice feature
about complex optimization and kind of
the reason why I went down this route
for good or for bad is that there is a
clear way of defining a dual function
based on where the solutions for the
dual complex combinations of gradients
so the symmetry between primal dual is
what I like in this framework and now
same reasoning as in the primal case
this guy and this guy may be smooth may
be non smooth you know you've got the
problem you can check based on whether
there was more Sano smooth you'll choose
your lower bound as either being the
function value or the average of the
function values at the point Z remember
Z bar is an average of disease you
really care about psystar a Z but these
may not be smooth you cannot discretize
it if that's the case we use the slower
smoother
lower bound any questions about all of
this
all right let's see if we can push and
naturally do Frank wolf before lunch
okay so back so let's apply all this big
cloud of potentially useless notions to
to the to the smooth optimization of a
polytope so again in general you have a
gradient or occurred and you have a
linear optimization you have this
gradient of the size tab and so the main
defining characteristic here is that
your f is moved and your science non
smooth so let's use that that means that
my upper bound should look like this
should have f of X bar because F is
motion and then it should contain
everything else in the upper bound and
upper bound should be the average so
here is the average of the size and here
is the average of the try styles and F
stars and cents what's happening here is
that in this problem between F and psy
and F star M psi star the only thing
which is smooth is F and that is
reflected in my construction of lower
bound and upper bound I'm going to
choose my you know the only place in
which I'm not using an average is for f
of X bar because F is most okay so once
I tell you this everything now the
algorithm will come out by itself let me
show you why
so you find this now we have a notion of
gap and now there is this invariant
which is important this is going to be
kind of the invariant in in all these
algorithms and invariant is
alpha t we can think of it so just time
times the current gap
so this I claim that our algorithm will
preserve this quantity why is that
helpful if effect actually I can ensure
that's it the algorithm preserve this
quantity that I know that after time T
my gap must be the initial gap over
alpha of T so alpha of T grows I'm
reducing the initial gap so I claim that
this is a natural notion of an invariant
you might like to keep in action this is
the invariant but all this for several
methods Monty okay so let's now the raft
is an exercise in differentiation and
for this example I'm going to do it with
you to show you how it works so remember
my invariant is alpha T plus 1 times GT
I'm gonna look at the contribution from
the upper bound and the lower bound
separately so in my upper bound I'm
differentiating with respect to time
this quantity and what I get so I have
two terms one from the smooth function
and one from this averaging and they're
going to differentiate in this way so
this term I have to apply the chain rule
so they apply the product rule so now
I'm gonna get two terms here I
differentiated alpha in here I
differentiate to the function so I get
inner product of the gradient and X bar
dot
or these guys differentiating these
averages is really easy because you can
use the fundamental theorem of calculus
and you just get sine of X T so notice
again and / - the only part of the only
part of your rate of change in which you
get in which you see a gradient is the
smooth part everything else is just
averaging function like this and lower
bound in the lower bound
everything was non smooth so it is just
one big average and this is what I get
now I put them together and I have this
expression so this this comes from my
smooth part and this comes from my non
smooth part and now remember that we
have defined X bar to be the average of
these points they came from the mirror
mat so you based on this you can
actually you know what X bar dot is you
know this quantity and so here I just
differentiated X bar to get X bar dot
now I'm gonna plug X bar in the air and
I'm gonna get this simpler expression
and again there is a smooth part and
then known as most part so what changed
is that this alpha t + 1 cancelled is
alpha t plus 1 and this term got
replaced to disturb
okay so now if this is if this is truly
an invariant I want this to be zero and
it turns out that there is only one way
you can make this zero and by using
conjugate duality and the idea is that
if you look about at F and a start
I'm sorry amps I start you really want
this to be conjugate pairs what do I
mean by conduits paths I mean that so I
mean this I mean so that XT is the mat
of ZT why do I want that because if
that's true that means that Phi star of
Z T plus Phi star of XT minus ZT x T is
zero that's by the definition of the
conjugate so if I if I make this choice
of X T I know that that
so I make this choice so that I can
cancel out these two terms and I'm gonna
get AZ txt component so all this known
as most part 2 becomes a professor I got
this Z txt and then same reasoning on
this most part although but now I don't
have a just an average of functions I
have some gradient and what's gonna
happen is that for this most part I'm
gonna need the ZT to be the gradient at
X bar again because these are conjugate
pairs now I got this expression and
everything cancels out I got zero so
this choice of maps makes this variant I
should the right way to think about it
is that if I tell you this invariant you
can derive that this must be the dynamic
and why is this what's the point of this
dynamic so this is the kind of picture
you want to keep in mind remember your
gradient of F F is most so what's gonna
happen is that the algorithm is gonna
take the current solution query the
gradient at the correct solution it's
gonna get this gradient and then it's
gonna take the same the very same
gradient and map it back notice that
this Z bar which is the current dual
solution is not a path to this dynamic
it's it's that it certifies things but
it doesn't intervene not using it okay
the reason for this is that this map
here is known as muth so you if you were
if you were trying to apply the gradient
of site star at the Z bar you would end
up with something that you cannot
discretize and that's why this picture
looks like this
okay so this is what does it mean in
terms of most optimization of a polytope
so we have this picture and these are
the definition of dynamic so what it
means is that I have some solution X bar
I queried the gradient this is the
gradient which we call Z of T then I
apply the mirror map per city so try in
the mirror map means I optimize this
linear function over the polytope and
it's going to give me X T XT is this
point and then what happens is because X
bar is an average I'm gonna add a bit of
X into a spot to get to my newest part
and this is exactly Frank wolf
and this also allows you to think a bit
about problems like know can we improve
Frankel's and yeah you can kind of the
main issue that you can see here is that
this map site star is non smooth and the
reason why is not smooth is that the
boundary of this polytope is known as
most there are these vertices you've got
something round then this map would be
smooth and you could do better than this
will become in a discretization that's
for the discretization do the saturation
and then we'll take a break and I'll let
you digest your lunch and this okay
so the nice thing about thinking about
upper bounds and lower bounds in terms
of either the function value or the
average of the function values is that
when you discretize the only terms you
make an error on the terms that look
like this whenever you are using
averages you really don't there is no
discretization cost because in some
sense this is lebesgue integral when you
average over function values as an exact
discrete counterpart you just averaging
function values in discrete time but
this guy this really depends on the
gradient at XT did this party you won't
be able to discretize exactly and so
with that's why when you do
discretization we'll think about what
happens when I go from this continuous
integral to a discrete version again I
need only need to worry about the blue
part which is the smooth part let's buy
that by design no I designed my function
ax so that I only need to do this so
here it's a the integral from going from
time
t plus one in continuous-time and what
the most basic thing I can do is forward
Euler and what does that mean
it means that instead of actually trying
to compute this red curve which is the
actual integral I'm gonna take the
gradient at time T and just estimate
this integral as this blue box and this
I'm gonna get this discretization error
and you can actually showed in this case
that discretization error is always
positive so the picture actually looks
like this okay so what does that mean
practice so here it's how it's going to
work we are gonna go from a continuous
measure to a discrete measure I'm gonna
call it a is my be the density capital a
is gonna be the cumulative function
averaging this averaging remains
averaging the discrete sense and you can
actually think of it this way and then
these two definitions don't contain
derivatives so we can just stick to them
and now I'm skipping like two lines of
computation that are pretty easy
actually and so to just give you an
expression for the discretization error
remember that this is our invariant we
really want this to be zero and it turns
out that if we apply this discretization
scheme as I defined you get this
discretization error and this is nice
for many reasons first it really
involves you know you have the F the
gradient of F and then the your mirror
map it's a natural thing to get and then
so in some sense once you hear once you
get to this point you can do a number of
things it really depends on what kind of
smoothness you have what do you know
about the problem so yeah this actually
is the place where are lots of fast
algorithm for specific sailing our
programs will diverge if you have more
structure you can do something different
here what people do in general
optimization is they use the definition
of smoothness and strong convexity that
I told you before and if you use that as
your notion of smoothness then your next
step would be to apply cauchy-schwarz
and then you can apply smoothness on
this side and you get this kind of
expression then here this is the
difference between two current points
using two averages so you can simplify
that that's going quickly through the
computation okay and you'll get to this
point now here you get XT and X bar T
these are two mirror maps so all this
point or the both these terms are
distances between points within your
polytop so these are really you can
replace it by the diameter squared so
this is the kind of discretization error
you get in one iteration and then you
just need to choose finally what this is
or what these alphas are going to be and
it turns out that if you want to balance
things
it the right choice of a is essentially
linear with I and you get this kind of
bound and notice that this bound here so
because a I is I capital a really scales
like T squared so if you only add the
continuous dynamic e you would you would
have this kind of convergence this term
C this term here comes millions with
addition and this is actually the bigger
term this is what dominates so this
shows that Frank or if you want to take
the gap down to epsilon you need T to be
like all the diameter squared over apps
and you know you can bound this term
this term you can show it must be
smaller than this and so I like you know
this might seem like a lot of work to
recover the simple result but once
you're at this point you can do many
other things for example you know there
is a different notion as most people use
which is called holder smoothness where
instead of having Norman norm you have a
norm and they have Norma to some power
same exact analysis you essentially use
the same scheme you're going to use
alders inequality instead of
cauchy-schwarz and and you get this
bound which is also the right bound for
this case if you have a different notion
of smoothness which comes from your
specific problem you can use it here
so I'm gonna stop now and then after
lunch I'm gonna talk a bit about dual
averaging which is the dual counterpart
of this and about acceleration and and a
few open questions
[Applause]
you have a line search in your analysis
because more things to cancel you need
to send them fixed right so I haven't
thought about trying search I have
examples where you can use you can
definitely have adaptive stat line but I
haven't talked about one solution you
have step lines which depend on the size
of the gradient is a square
but so that we'll talk about it after
lunch for exoteric when you get into
accelerated methods forward Euler is not
enough to get the right convergence and
then you have two choices
there is a little trick which gives you
master of accelerated gradient descent
and then there is a way to go into
that's more like approximate backward
order which also gives you the same kind
of convergence then so that's a good
we'll talk about this kind of
discretization techniques that are
helpful is an interesting area of
research
the continuous domain things are
complicated because you can really have
an arbitrary fast so I need to achieve
level there is some terms to that but
it's I cannot quite make it exact
I cannot most on an algebraic level if
you go to the proof your intuition is
correct
but I don't know really after make it
if there's no further question that
think they learn it again
[Applause]
[Music]